clearly one of the big challenges of
this question is there's just so much
information this is a theme that you
will see throughout all of mathematics
that our brains are only so large right
it's the reason why you can't multiply
five digit numbers in your head there's
nothing difficult about addition sorry
multiplication or the addition that
comes with it there's just too much of
it and that's why if I gave you paper
and a bit of time you probably could do
five digit numbers in your head right
because you would break it down into a
series of smaller problems and then
you'd be fine this is like a pair of
five digit numbers that you've got to
multiply in your head in its current
form so what I want to do again
something we've seen all the way
throughout this course is try and break
up the problem into smaller pieces
that's what I've got down here
okay now do you notice we've got
triangles we've got quadrilaterals
flying everywhere they all overlap that
makes it challenging so what I've pulled
that is just triangle ABC and triangle
abd I've pulled them both out because
they share this common sight here and
we've already noticed in this course
before if you can look at the same
object from two different angles you
almost always gain insight so I want you
to look at ABC for a second ABC there
are some lengths in this diagram ABC
that I haven't put on there they come
from the original one for example BC BC
you see how it's got F in in this spot
here what is F in relation to BC what is
F in relation to BC it's the midpoint
right there that's how it's constructed
so I'm just label those in maybe you
want to have this supplementary diagram
in some corner on your page as well but
AC is also a similar relationship here
isn't it can you see where AC is can you
see where AC is and so K is it's a bad
diagram here but K is also the midpoint
of AC do you see that I think I labeled
that is six okay now think back to the
first property we proved today what did
that tell you about f k we've got these
similar triangles here which means that
F K must be parallel to the
sigh do you agree it's the interval that
joins the midpoints and so it's parallel
to the third side okay so we know that
this is true but now come over here
isn't this stage IV there's a lot of
debris in this diagram okay B D what is
B D it's the diagonal of the big
quadrilateral right and we form L by
bisecting B do in exactly the same way
ad is right down here down the bottom
it's also being bisected so tell me what
you know about a b and LH they're
parallel but what i want you to notice
is they're both the same parallel they
both have to be the same parallel
because look a b is the same side in
both triangles right so what does that
tell you about FK and LH
they're parallel as well so you see by
looking at it the same side this guy
from do different can you bring it over
to this big diagram now you can see that
this is parallel to this but this is
also parallel to this so they are
parallel to each other does that make
sense okay I can rehearse this argument
I won't redraw it because it's the same
thing is over here I can rehearse this
argument for F L and K H can you see the
triangles that they live in
what triangle does FL live in that I can
use this relationship with yeah I can
see it BC D it's that big one over there
so you can see that this side is going
to be parallel over here do you see it
because it's been formed by joining the
midpoints of B C D so here's the third
side but this third side is in another
triangle do you see it what's it called
yeah you see it you're starting to see
through the diagram to the structure is
there a C D it's the same deal loop like
so okay so now we know that this sky is
a parallelogram in a parallelogram we
know that the diagonals bisect each
other this is
property we learnt like a couple of
years ago under quadrilaterals okay so
this tells us number one that F let's
give this guy in the middle the name
let's call him oh because he's right
there in the middle okay this tells us
that firstly F L H K is a parallelogram
I won't write all the reasoning up
because we just talked through all the
reasoning and you can put all the
letters down yourself it's a
parallelogram therefore what can we say
here fo equals H and K equals L because
diagonals bisect each other
in a parallelogram that is they don't
always in all quadrilaterals so that's
really nice
where can I go from there well do you
remember the very first construction you
made you can see I've got these orange
diagonals this guy here has been created
by joining the midpoints of the biggest
quadrilateral that you can see so if I
look at EFG H clearly what kind of shape
is it it's a it's a parallelogram just
like we did before okay so if it's a
parallelogram then what does that tell
you about its diagonals they also
mutually bisect each other now they
share a diagonal these two
quadrilaterals I just looked at the red
dog one and the orange dotted one sorry
red and orange that was a bad choice on
my part but you can see if they both
mutually bisect each other then I've got
a o equals o G in this bigger
parallelogram so I'm gonna say a F G H
is a parallelogram
for that reason over there therefore e
equals o G now if these two
parallelograms mutually by sets they
have mutually bisecting diagonals and
they actually share a diagonal then all
of them have to bisect each other all at
that one spot which is what your
original construction proved in the
beginning or showed anyway okay so I'm
done there you go we've proved it it
looked like a disaster to begin with in
fact I'd say if Hori looks more like a
disaster now but you can see through the
structure now because you recognize
shapes in there that you wouldn't have
been equipped to see before okay